[Applause]
[Music]
we're all knee-deep in the new school
year now so if you're looking forward to
some game filled weekends good news
almost all of this week's big games
launched on Friday and if you're all
about the new sports season starting up
we've got that covered too don't forget
to hit that subscribe button to get all
this stuff delivered right to you every
Sunday now let's dive into some of this
week's hottest games we'll start off
with something for the RPG crowd
divinity original sin 2 picks up right
after the original where the newly
outlawed sorcerers must band together to
take down Bishop Alexander the one who
made them outcasts in the first place
what this means for the role-playing
side of things is a party of up to 4
spell casters skill crafting and a love
and hate system that keeps track of your
friendly and romantic relationships with
other characters and if you want to turn
those mechanics on each other you can
jump into team vs. team multiplayer
divinity original sin 2 comes to PC on
Thursday September 14th with ps4 and
Xbox one releases coming later speaking
of games with a lot of different skills
death of the outsider is a standalone
expansion for last year's Dishonored 2
as the name implies your goal is to take
down the mysterious and ultra powerful
outsider fortunately you've got a slew
of new powers to do that including some
handy dandy hook mines you'll also have
the option of taking down additional
targets using the expansions new
contracts feature your mission begins on
ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday the 15th
but if you want to see the game in
action right now we've got over half an
hour of gameplay you can check out maybe
you prefer outerspace two cities with a
well punk aesthetic in that case check
out Metroid Samus returns this
reimagining of 1991's Metroid 2 brings
some great new tweaks to samus his
adventure for starters she has a melee
attack for dealing critical damage to
enemies and can freely aim in any
direction
classic power-ups like the super
missiles and grapple Beamer back
alongside new upgrades like the scan
pulse which can help you locate secret
items and passages Samus returns on 3ds
on the 15 let's come back down to earth
with the great sport of hockey NHL 18 is
bringing a bunch of new features to the
rink including tons of options for
maneuvering the puck around or stealing
it from your opponents perhaps the
biggest addition is the new threes mode
which drops you into faster paced
three-on-three matches you can take a
shot on ps4 and Xbox one on the 15th I
just hope all these violent hockey games
aren't influencing our kids also
dribbling onto the court this week is
NBA Live 18 just like its hockey cousin
NBA Live has some new tricks up its
sleeve first the career mode gives you a
choice between rising through the league
or coming up from Street games second
special animations and signature moves
make actual players seem that much more
real but the biggest change is the
addition of the WNBA which basically
doubles all your options for players and
teams you can tip off on ps4 and Xbox
one on the 15th and those are some of
the hottest games we'll be playing this
week as always remember that release
dates are based on retailer listings and
are subject to change thanks for
watching guys and I'll be back with
another batch of new releases next week